[Music]
dr. bassem youssef is a television
comedian he used satirical comedy to
hold the authorities to account during
the Egyptian revolution he was a symbol
of the promise of the Arab Spring and of
its ultimate failure when demonstrations
began in 2011 dr. Yusef quit his job as
a heart surgeon to start a comedy show
on YouTube his wit and satire poked fun
at the hypocrisy of the state-run media
which tried to discredit the protests
and it quickly became a smash hit he was
one man standing against the regime with
no weapons but his jokes and it soon
made him an enemy of the state as a
longtime cartoonist for The Economist
and fellow satirist I was interested in
his story I wanted to talk with Bassam
now in exile in the United States about
those tumultuous times there's nothing
like a good dictator to get the cartoon
juices going
living under a dictator for 30 years
that's like most of your life it you
don't know anything else maybe your
first exposure to anything political
could be a revolution and that's exactly
what happened to me the success of his
YouTube channel led to a television deal
his weekly satirical show al Berna may
soon became the most viewed television
program in the Middle East with 30
million viewers per episode
[Music]
as part of the show he took to the
streets to interview protesters as the
government used force to try and silence
them but making jokes in such a serious
situation wasn't always funny even when
I was doing field pieces and speaking to
people who were like under fire and had
like teargas thrown in them one time I
was joking with a guy that said that a
good quality tear gas the you guys are
receiving and the guy but yeah but the
guy that I was treating died as like you
can see in the movie how that damn smile
got wiped off my face in two seconds why
why did I ask this question and why does
that keep this footage the director told
me no we need to keep it as I don't want
this this makes me look like a jerk
yesterday he said I can no but you're
also showing people that this is real
people but the people would not be
silenced and nor would use of the mass
protests forced President Hosni Mubarak
to step down democratic elections
followed and Mohamed Morsi of the Muslim
Brotherhood was elected there was kind
of this state of unpredictability nobody
knew how far can we go in satire we were
placing bets which episode will be the
last for bassam's brand of satire was
getting him fans from outside Egypt he
soon earned the nickname the Egyptian
Jon Stewart ladies and gentlemen I also
just do it in Egypt which is something
that I'm very proud of thing is the
satire puts you like gets you into
trouble I mean what about the love we
get from the people I'll tell you this
it doesn't get me the kind of trouble
that gets you into if your regime is not
strong enough to handle the joke then
you don't have a regime
everybody wondered if democracy could
take root in Arabian soil it didn't take
long for the people to turn against the
Morsi government and his failed policies
protesters now started to demand morsi's
resignation and the military stepped in
Morsi may be a temptation to police by
the killer
let me finish today picketed General
Abdul Fattah al-sisi the army chief
deposed President Morsi it was a coup in
all but name
[Applause]
Yusuf's attempt to ridicule general
al-sisi were not tolerated by the regime
the state increasingly jammed his
broadcasts and threatened him with
lawsuits this time though the military
man had some popular support
it was unthinkable to even bring up the
name of CC in comedy I mean he was not
just there if not the room he was the
elephant in the room now you were
dealing not just for likely the dictator
or tyrant he had the people the mood
around Yusuf's show changed protestors
regularly gathered outside his studio he
was arrested on several occasions and
eventually the show was taken off the
air in 2014 when everything was coming
to an end I had to tell everybody it's
gonna be over because basically there
was pressure on the hosting channel and
no one would be brave enough to hostess
in the West us satirist s' don't often
live in fear of our own government but
suddenly we had new threats to consider
so this idea of the red lines and
religion first came to a head but the
Charlie Hebdo killing in Paris because
of the drawings that appeared in the
magazine of the Prophet so I did a
cartoon that showed that hate had
actually won at least they had won that
skirmish what the great publicity to say
religion right yes you know it's just
like isn't it crazy it's like oh we are
a peaceful religion to you which is
actually affects other people who are
really peaceful
Yusuf's fall from grace with sudden but
the legacy left behind will last what
you did in Egypt you did break you know
barriers that no one had thought of for
decades it's only people like you who
have started and done things and if you
cast the seeds and to be other
generations to come forward satire is
just a byproduct of freedom of
expression you have freedom of
expression you have real democracy you
gonna have something they say it let
laughter be thy medicine right you're a
doctor you ought to know
yeah so it's kind of like I I think I
never left
Bassem is now forging a career in
America I hope his brand of satire and
the freedom that it represented has not
gone forever
[Music]